hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Breanna
white today we're gonna check out from
all-time movies this be your child star
[ __ ] you in the ass screw you up anyway
we're gonna check this out
I want to tell you yes that that's a
short version of this video is yes it
[ __ ] you up so that's all you want it
you can Lea never heard of a guy growing
up from being a child so everything's
great no it [ __ ] you up
DiCaprio handle well hey guys I'm Chris
I'm Gerry Jamie I want to ask you a
question I'll give you an answer yeah
does being a child star screw you up
royally
it doesn't really screw you up
it doesn't even vanilla screw you up
look some people are always gonna screw
up regardless of whatever career they
career path they take but there are
plenty of examples of people who started
in the game young I turned out just fine
okay
you look like a vampire and seen
Twilight well I bet if you did you'd
wank over Kristen Stewart she began her
film career as a teenager and panic we
remember that one with Jodie fine the
single mile in the big house well the
bit you don't remember from the film
Kristen Stewart is in it
bin chef asthma yes but that's not hey
panic room could have her over big time
that was a big movie for someone so
young but she had at that movie well she
took it in her stride and a few years
later what comes along the Twilight
franchise and now she's the biggest
thing around she's just been in a
fantastic movie with Jesse Eisenberg
she's taking over Hollywood watch this
space what space you say she were hit
from penny groom
- freakin Twilight are you telling me
she isn't screwed up Chris she's worth
17 million dollars she could have a
meltdown leave the film industry and she
would never go hungry again
cuz she's loaded yeah okay Jamie but you
know who else was successful who Shia
LeBouf e the beef the beef let's
translate shy shy of the beef he made a
lot of money became buddies with Steven
Spielberg Indiana Jones dream job and he
fed up and then you put a bag on his
head he plagiarized Daniel Clowes then
he goes onto YouTube and this is just a
tional sq that's bad [ __ ] crazy the best
thing about Charlie book is that song
about child above killing other people
because he's Shia LaBeouf what about the
song by the Icelandic band a he's in the
music video with his Willy yeah yeah
that's the real beef so has he gone off
the rails completely in some would say
in a kind of mental way maybe he miss me
definitely look it sure definitely I'll
level with you you know even after all
this crazy [ __ ] has happened he was in
fury and all the people liked that movie
it was in the movie for like five
minutes
I think he's trolling us I think he's
having a bit of fun and I think he knows
we're suckers Chris because we've been
trolled before we're Joaquin Phoenix
[ __ ] yeah yeah okay okay you got his
best role words what Dumb and Dumber oh
[Music]
yeah you saved the day that's a real
hero but since then it's time for a real
hero a real human being
[Music]
mom what about drawing drivers [ __ ]
that's a great movie I like that movie
yeah Ryan Gosling Mickey Mouse Club make
it a Christina Aguilera
what's up Mickey Mouse Club and Britney
we're sorry that much stronger
that guy was in the head yes I heard
he's in a band where they changed the
solders at the
it's a great across a change music -
like scrotum scrotum screwed I cannot
tell you what the original track that
was Macaulay Culkin right he was doing
so well
home alone Richie Rich even but yeah he
just kind of like snorted too much coke
had a little bit too much Jesus juice
and he strikes me as the kind of person
who might be actively taking his step
away from the limelight you know cuz he
had a rough experience his parents were
pretty tight in terms of how they
control his finances we don't know how
much of the money he made at that age
that he actually saw in the long run
lead master this isn't to me we don't
know he doesn't talk very much she said
but maybe that's not his choice maybe he
doesn't want to be out of the spotlight
maybe he's forced to be out of the
spotlight because he's cooked in the
head maybe he did get caught with pot on
his person once didn't they not pot
that's a sin I wonder if he uses
aftershave probably not and speaking of
home alone what about Christian Bale
what what about me I'm higher in the Sun
he's in Hanoi wasn't was his girlfriend
oh okay maybe Christian Bale wasn't in
home alone he was uncredited but he was
a child star he was in Empire of the Sun
when he was just 13 years old
what can we turned out he's Batman he's
Moses he's uh an Oscar winner okay fair
enough increased that he's all of them
yeah but but two bars from being so well
built in Batman 2 like the machinist and
the fighter who is just literally
literally in the case of machinist a
skeleton of his former self that's not
healthy surely there's something
mentally wrong with him but ridiculous
dieting aside he has done another two
good films he has won a number of awards
and made himself and studios and other
talented people a lot of money I think
he's crazy
lots of child actors have gone on to win
Oscars Jodie Foster was really really
young when she was in taxi driver I look
she turned out just fine
[Music]
and you know another child actor Chris
that later went on to an Oscar all that
detail just from memory sir yes I do
you're not at the cafe are ya I was
going to talk about Robert Downey jr.
okay number Chaplin way back in the 90s
oh the 90s mean before his drug abuse he
came back from those problems yeah okay
yeah yeah you did you did I mean he he
is Iron Man after all he is iron eye
like you said at the end of the first
iron man right before this song iron man
played I am Iron Man
pictures while to get any traction I'll
give you that one
just look at all the Marvel stuff he's
making loads of money he's making loads
of fans he's doing great he even didn't
go full [ __ ] I think that there are
these people out there right yeah
everyone is a human being and I think
people in general on mats are always
going to like differentiate in terms of
how susceptible they're going to be how
easily they will be loading by drugs and
by drink yeah and then you might make an
argument that children in Hollywood are
around these things and offered these
things and have these things available
to them at an earlier age and perhaps in
greater volume but I think it's down to
the individual to turn a blind eye to
those negative influences and make a
career for themselves and I think there
are far too many people who have done it
to defend the people who could never
sell okay Jaime but for every Jodie
Foster and every Robert Downey jr. you
get the inverse and you get yourself a
Lindsay Lohan
I mean sure is absolutely stunning
around that period of Mean Girls which
was a great film as well she made me
feel Herbie fully loaded I'll hand it to
you say the best to last I hope you
bleed she's someone she had it all going
her way she was really really young in
Parent Trap and things like Mean Girls
seems to suggest that she could
transition from that you know that child
star to that teenager of adolescence
yeah yeah she threw away in pretty
astonishing style and she still can't
get over her problems I'll give you that
one
she yes I mean she's breaking the law
she's what she's partying an upgrade I
mean
maybe she's not that upset about it you
cut up because she's having the time
maybe Chris let's take off the Lindsay
Lohan herself and end this on a high hey
guys there was me and Jamie talking
about child stars who will be the
screwed up or heaven who's right me
right or me obviously right wrong right
don't forget to Like and subscribe leave
a comment below with any other examples
that you can think of and we will see
you soon it has to end here hey guys and
much like child stars here is our video
on why movies go wrong check it out yeah
click it
I do think being a child star is can be
quite impactful in a negative way
because I think for as actors it's
usually best to wait till you're at
least you know an adult you have to
gather life experiences and you gotta
know people and stuff and then when you
become a star people can be kind of
two-dimensional to you and the way they
treat you their interaction with you
will be different because you're a star
what's interesting about the idea of
celebrity is that you end up becoming a
commodity you end up becoming an object
to be sold what's interesting is with
any other business your object is is
something aside from you but when you're
a celebrity your image the thing that
you're selling is actually yourself yeah
and as an adult you can separate those
two things and say okay yeah I'm selling
this image or whatever but this is me
this I can't give away this belongs to
me but as a child you can't separate
those two things and your head gets big
because you say oh I'm worth a lot of
money when the truth is your image is
worth a lot of money your movies are
worth your money and you have to be able
to separate yourself from those things
me McCoy Calkins a classic example of
that I mean it was so sad because he was
the definition of a child star yeah no
absolutely you say Macaulay Culkin
everyone knows who that child star is
Haley Joel Osment seemed like he was on
his way with like a dramatic take
they're like oh this is a great young
dramatic child actor the debate of being
a does a child star does a child star
screw you up I think you gotta still
have really
good parenting yeah I think it still
comes back to the parenting and there's
a lot more protection now for child
stars than there was before I mean there
are so many rules and regulations now
surrounding like how they can collect
money and how much the parents are
allowed to cannot collect there's always
gonna be issues when your mom is your
manager
case in point Lindsay Lohan yeah classic
classic example of how it can all go
completely completely wrong although you
know what I like to see is stories like
Robert Downey jr. because a lot of these
stars even though they do go crazy for a
little while we do get the joy of seeing
them on the other side yeah really
exciting and DiCaprio was definitely a
child star after he did What's Eating
Gilbert Grape and he is one of the best
actors around right now I never hear
about crazy [ __ ] going on with him in
the media like he seems like he's got
his [ __ ] together and he's one of the
most talented actors out there right now
and it's a weird predicament to be in
because as a person who loves movies and
television it's like sometimes you need
a child actor in there and you want them
to be a wonderful child actor you don't
want to see some shitty child actor so
when they're great it's like well
they're gonna get the attention and
stuff so it's like there's stigma
against being a child star but at the
same time we kind of expect children to
be in movies I noticed with a lot of
these child stars they tend to kind of
disappear for a while and doubt react I
think while they're gone for a while
that's when they can really recollect
themselves becoming a mature adult and
then they kind of go back into the
business and stuff and go gung-ho
because it wasn't like DiCaprio and and
Christian Bale were suddenly like
household names and then they you know
they revolutionized the business in some
way they were out of the spotlight for a
while and they come back in and they own
it so I think if you do become a child
star there should be a point I like I'm
not opposed against child stars but I
feel like there should be a period in
their life as they're growing up where
they do take a break from it absolutely
Lindsay Lohan did not have wow this is a
really meaningful heartfelt conversation
we have well these are all it's weird
because child stars you just end up
caring about them so much
I would unlike today drew barrymore when
she was in the drugs though oh yeah see
there like she would have been fun
footage of the party with she would have
been fun to party wait why do you love
him - yeah sure i party with Lindsay
Lohan yeah I mean sure I'm like you her
and I would watch porn together that
again really yeah anyway guys we do the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out Rihanna's
Facebook page because this week she'll
be also supposedly maybe who knows let's
find out that she might be relaunching
her channel there's already some videos
there but she has some content she wants
to provide for you guys so keep a
lookout for that check out the channel
in the meantime and you can follow the
real rejects on Facebook Instagram
Twitter vine periscope because if we get
enough followers we can get product
placement for things such as electronic
cigarettes electronic cigarettes are
great you know why Rihanna because yes
this is e cigarette fluid the other
thing is you can get marijuana fluid and
you can smoke it in public and people
will be like oh it's just an e-cigarette
so then you can get high while you're at
Chipotle I don't support that yeah you
do no yeah you do really hope you're not
actually sponsoring that you cigarettes
yeah why no it's awful for you what do
you mean they're they're terrible for
you there it's still nicotine it's still
addictive it's better than smoking real
cigarettes it is better than smoking
real cigarettes but there's no
regulation on how they're made there's
there's no not enough studies done there
is one study that says that a lot of
formaldehyde comes out in secondhand
e-cigarettes milk so is that like a type
of sex position formaldehyde yeah no
it's a very awful chemical should not go
in your body there are many things I put
in my body many things sometimes it
hurts most of the time I like the pain
ISA grits